So now I want to have a quiz to see that you understand multiple inheritance and
see where it can get tricky. So suppose we add an init method to both the Black
Bear and the Discerning Bear classes, and that init method is going to use
super, passing in the Black Bear here, passing in Discerning Bear here, calling
init, but adding to the name. Black in front of a Black Bear and Discerning in
front of a Discerning Bear. Then, we'll define Discerning Black Bear with two
based classes, the Discerning Bear and the Black Bear and no attributes defined
inside the Discerning Black Bear. Then, we'll create an instance of the
Discerning Black Bear passing in Mortimer as the name. And I'll give you five
choices, it could be Mortimer, it could be Black Mortimer, it could be
Discerning Mortimer, it could be Black Discerning Mortimer, or it could be
Discerning Black Mortimer. What do you think Mortimer's name will be?